erklärungen und widerspruch die
kanzlerin verteidigt die neuen core ohne
regeln im bundestag die opposition wirft
ihr vor das parlament zu übergehen
terror in nizza ein mutmaßlicher
islamist tötete drei menschen in einer
kirche in frankreich gilt jetzt die
höchste warnstufe und dortmund jubelt
die borussen feiern einen arbeitssieg in
der champions league und leipzig
kassiert 5 tore in manchester
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und bei uns heute um 7
es ist viel passiert heute wir berichten
gleich über den terror in frankreich
beginnen mit der kroner lage und haben
natürlich auch den sport in der sendung
mit kristin otto schönen guten abend
die kanzlerin hatte einiges zu erklären
heute im parlament das land steht vor
einem neuen teilweisen lockdown die
eingriffe durch die neuen regeln ins
tägliche leben auch in grundrechte sind
massiv angela merkel spricht von einem
schweren winter im bundestag heute gibt
es auch scharfe kritik am kurs der
regierung es gibt zwischenrufe und die
forderung entscheiden müsse das
parlament
andreas rupp hat fasst zusammen maske
und manuskript mit diesem rüstzeug geht
angela merkel in ihrer
regierungserklärung gut 25 minuten in
denen sie rechtfertigt warum sich die
menschen im land auf harte
einschränkungen einstellen müssen
maßnahmen die wir jetzt ergreifen müssen
sind geeignet erforderlich und
verhältnismäßig die afg kann merkel
nicht überzeugen lautstark der protest
so laut dass der bundestagspräsident
eingreifen erläutert in einer
regierungserklärung die maßnahmen wenn
ich wenn sie den präsidenten
unterbrechen kriegen sie gleich
ordnungsrufe dass ich gefährlich scharf
kritisiert die kanzlerin in ihrer rede
all jene die die korona pandemie leugnen
lüge und der information verschwörung
und hass beschädigen nicht nur die
demokratische debatte sondern auch den
kampf gegen das ihre corona diktatur
sondern die afg merkels maßnahmen
es handelt sich um eine art
kriegspropaganda wozu ja auch passt dass
wir neuerdings von einer art klicks
kabinett dem corona kabinett regiert
werden auch von den anderen
oppositionsparteien gibt es gegenwind
wenn auch im ton gemäßigter fdp und
linke beklagen die fehlende einbindung
des parlaments
frau merkel wir haben gesagt debatte
stärke die demokratie das ist richtig
dafür muss die debatte aber vor der
entscheidung stattfinden man kann mit
der bevölkerung nicht so umgehen
das war nur in diesen fragen regiert in
der ministerpräsidenten runde oder
abwechselnd dann mal wieder ein podcast
das geht wirklich nicht die grünen
mahnen die regierung habe die nötigen
maßnahmen nicht richtig erklärt und so
ist aus der infektions krise eben auch
eine vertrauenskrise geworden und die
gilt es jetzt zu beheben mit großer
kraft und mit entschlossenheit und mit
gemeinsamen als stimme der länder wird
die rheinland pfälzische
ministerpräsident in für die gemeinsamen
beschlüsse nicht die gesetze allein
schützen die menschen der entscheidende
schlüssel für den erfolg bleibt das
vertrauen der bürger und bürgerinnen die
neu aufgelegten corona maßnahmen sind
harte kritik der parlamentarischen
opposition an der bundesregierung ist es
auch geeignet erforderlich
verhältnismäßig so verteidigt die
kanzlerin die neuen scharfen regeln für
november
gucken wir noch mal kurz drauf das
oberste ziel heißt kontakte reduzieren
die aufforderung keine besucher mehr
auch nicht bei verwandten keine ausflüge
keine privaten reisen
alle restaurants und bars müssen
schließen genau wie kinos theater
fitnessstudios freizeitparks den
unternehmen und selbstständigen die
davon direkt betroffen sind verspricht
die regierung jetzt schnelle hilfe
für die sich orientiert am umsatz der
betroffenen im november vor einem jahr
anselm stern virus herbst in deutschland
fühlt sich immer mehr an wie im virus
frühjahr ein tag nach harten corona
entscheidungen so vieles muss wieder
dicht gemacht so vieles wieder abgesagt
werden
ich denke das ist ein wichtiger schritt
ist er lieber früher als später
ich glaube das wird sich viel im
privaten raum verschieben ich kann
selbst genug leute die hier ja die krone
maßnahmen nicht ernst genug nehmen
leider auch wenn ich mich zu hause mit
zehn leuten aus zwei haushalten treffen
kann verstehe ich nicht warum ich nicht
mit einer freundin ins café gehen kann
das sieht man hier in düsseldorf genauso
eine traditionsbrauerei ausschenken
arbeiten ab montag wieder verboten
obwohl so viel investiert wurde
wir haben die lüftungsanlage umgebaut
wir haben plexiglasscheiben angeschafft
wir haben draußen in heizstrahler
investiert wir sind jetzt quasi stadt
herum ein crooner konformes herbst
geschäft betreiben zu können und jetzt
wird uns der hahn zugedreht
eine notlage aber es wird geholfen sagen
heute finanz und wirtschaftsminister
gemeinsam in berlin
der plan solo selbstständige und kleine
unternehmen mit weniger als 50
mitarbeitern sollen bis zu 75 prozent
erstattet bekommen von ihrem umsatz und
zwar vom umsatz aus dem november vor
einem jahr bei den größeren unternehmen
wird das etwas weniger sein trotzdem ist
das eine hilfe die unmittelbar massiv
wirkt der kollege scholz und ich wir
waren uns einig dass es darum geht in
diesem fall noch einmal nicht zu
kleckern sondern klotzen zehn milliarden
euro kosten die hilfen den steuerzahler
für den einen monat geht nicht anders
sagt die regierung und auch der
städtetag
ich glaube es muss sein und wir werden
noch viele viele jahrzehnte natürlich an
den folgen zu tragen haben aber das
gehört dazu das gehört zu wald es sind
virus krisen programme und maßnahmen mit
enormen folgen für das ganze land mehr
zum kampf gegen das virus gleich in
dieser sendung erst das zweite wichtige
thema heute ein tag des terrors in
frankreich heute morgen wieder ein ganz
offensichtlich islamistischer anschlag
der tatort die kirche notre dame in
nizza ein mann ruft allahu akhbar sticht
mit einem messer zu
er tötet drei menschen und verletzt
sechs weitere das land ruft die höchste
warnstufe aus paris mehr jetzt von
christel haas wir haben gerade erfahren
dass es ein brutales attentat und nizza
gegeben hat sagt der parlamentspräsident
die nachricht platzt mitten in die
debatte über den neuen coroner lockdown
alle erheben sich zu einer
schweigeminute
es ist kurz nach neun polizisten stürmen
in die basilika von nizza schuss
gefallen
drinnen hat ein attentäter besucher mit
einem messer angegriffen
ein mann und eine frau sind sofort tot
eine zweite frau schwer verletzt nach
draußen stirbt aber kurz darauf die
polizei schießt auf den mutmaßlichen
täter einen 21 jährigen tunesier
er wird festgenommen der angreifer hat
nicht aufgehört allahu akbar rufen
während der medizinisch versorgt wurde
präsident makro trifft am frühen
nachmittag in nizza ein und spricht von
einem islamistischen terroranschlag
wir sind heute wieder wegen unserer
werte angegriffen worden
für unsere liebe zur freiheit wir werden
uns nicht unterkriegen lassen
doch die gefahr bleibt die zahl der
soldaten die in frankreich zum schutz
vor anschlägen eingesetzt werden wird
verdoppelt auf 7.000 frankreich kämpft
seit langem gegen einen zunehmend
radikalen islamismus im eigenen land
erst vor kurzem hatte präsident max
schärfere maßnahmen gegen islamisten
angekündigt
in ganz frankreich läuteten heute die
kirchenglocken im gedenken an die die
einem weiteren anschlag zum opfer
gefallen sind
[Musik]
nach der enthauptung des lehrer samuel
partie vor zwei wochen hatte der
französische präsident karikaturen des
propheten mohammed verteidigt und gesagt
islamisten hätten es auf die zukunft des
landes abgesehen
die folge eine welle von wut und zorn in
teilen der islamischen welt
christoph distel jetzt über frankreich
religion und terror fast zwei wochen ist
es her
der lehrer samuel partie wird auf
offener straße enthauptet weil er im
unterricht die meinungsfreiheit erklärt
hat mit den mohammed-karikaturen aus
verliert so als beispiel die tat macht
frankreich fassungslos einmal mehr denn
der riss zwischen westlicher und
islamischer welt verläuft hier schon
lange quer durchs land paris 2015 nutzer
2016 viele anschläge haben das den
franzosen eingeprägt fünf millionen
muslime etwa leben in frankreich die ein
gut integriert andere nicht ghettos
armut perspektivlosigkeit ein ungelöstes
problem und dauerthema in dieser
atmosphäre hält präsident mal kommt
seine trauerrede für partie und
verspricht man werde die terroristen
brechen die islamisten im land klein
bekommen schnell läuft die sache
international aus dem ruder
der türkische präsident erdogan wittert
einen angriff auf den gesamten islam
empfiehlt makro sich wegen psychischer
probleme untersuchen zu lassen und
fordert boykottiert französische waren
viele arabische länder steigern sich mit
in rage
von marokko bis katar darauf legte in
frankreich charlie hebdo mit einer
erdogan karikatur nach privat ist er
sehr nett heißt es da dazu eine
bildpunkte im gewohnten stil des blattes
vorgestern war das westliches denken
kollidiert mit dem islam
und viele macht das wütend nicht nur in
ankara oder kairo
auch in frankreich selbst der
islamistische terror erschüttert
frankreich seit jahren es gab bereits
über 250 opfer thomas walde ist unser
korrespondent in paris wo eine strikte
masken pflicht gilt guten abend thomas
fangen wir vielleicht mit einer frage an
die sich gerade heute wieder viele
stellen warum immer wieder frankreich
also die meinungsfreiheit hat hier in
der französischen republik einen hohen
stellenwert als vor kurzem charlie hebdo
die mohammed-karikaturen noch einmal
veröffentlicht hat bekam die zeitschrift
dafür sehr viel unterstützung präsident
marco hat ausdrücklich das recht auf
gotteslästerung verteidigt andererseits
hat die republik in der bombe den
sozialen brennpunkten probleme mit
jugendlichen oft aus einwanderer
familien die sich benachteiligt fühlen
was sich radikale prediger versuchen zu
nutze zu machen und der stadt hat dem
nicht immer was entgegenzusetzen
wegen der strikten trennung von staat
und religion hier hat der staat in der
vergangenheit beispielsweise kaum
gemäßigte imame selbst ausgebildet
welchen plan hat denn die politik jetzt
um diesen terror zu begegnen ihn zu
stoppen
das ist mehrschichtig auf der einen
seite hat präsident mag eben die mit her
präsenz jetzt erhöht auf 7.000 soldaten
die sensible objekte schützen sollen
auf der anderen seite wird am kommenden
montag wenn die herbstferien beendet
sind in den schulen noch einmal
besonders auch auf das recht auf
meinungsfreiheit hingewiesen
es wird demnächst ein buch
veröffentlicht werden das im unterricht
verwendet werden soll noch einmal
ausdrücklich unter bezugnahme auf die
karikaturen beispielsweise aber man muss
sagen es gibt auch durchaus
unterschiedliche ansätze
marine le pen von der radikalen rechten
fordert eine art kriegsrecht um den
islamismus hier im land zu bekämpfen und
jeder neue anschlag ist wasser auf ihre
mühlen und stellt erneut den
zusammenhalt der gesellschaft auf eine
harte probe
nochmals vielen dank für diese analyse
nach paris und wir bleiben noch einen
moment in frankreich der terror trifft
das land in einer sowieso schwierigen
zeit denn ab morgen gilt wieder ein
landesweiter lockdown einen monat lang
dürfen die franzosen wir zu hause nur
noch aus triftigem grund verlassen
bars restaurants und viele geschäfte
müssen schließen
anders als im frühjahr sollen die
schulen aber offen bleiben drastisch
auch die entwicklung in der schweiz dort
wurden innerhalb eines tages mehr als
9300 neue fälle gemeldet die schweiz hat
nur ein zehntel der einwohner von
deutschland
und hier sind die zahlen in deutschland
da gibt es wieder einen neuen
höchststand das robert koch institut
registrierte innerhalb von 24 stunden 16
1774 neue corona fälle ein trend der
sich auch bei den neuinfektionen im 7
tagesschnitt zeigt der liegt bei 12 1720
davor waren es knapp über 11.000 auch
die zahl der kogit 19 patienten auf
intensivstationen steigt die zahl freier
betten sei zwar noch ausreichend sagen
intensivmediziner sie warnen aber vor
einer drohenden lücke beim personal
torge bode berichtet von der
intensivstation im klinikum aachen
vieles ist für chefarzt professor gernot
marx rund oberärztin dr alle brücken
routine wenn sie den streng
abgeriegelten teil der intensivstation
betreten
12 19 patienten werden derzeit an der
uniklinik aachen behandelt dieser
patient ist 48 jahre alt und genau da
liegt der unterschied zur ersten welle
während der ersten welle mussten den
spitzenzeiten knapp 50 corona
patientinnen und patienten hier an der
uni klinik künstlich beatmet werden
eine hohe belastung für das gesamte
personal doch jetzt profitiert man auch
von den gesammelten erfahrungen wie man
die zweite welle hier bewältigen wird
hängt nicht zuletzt vom klinikpersonal
ab engpässe gibt es teilweise schon
jetzt durch eigene ansteckung mit 19
oder quarantänebestimmungen
und denen die jetzt wieder an vorderster
front kämpfen steckt noch immer die
belastung der ersten welle in den
knochen
zwei prozent der mit krone infizierten
müssen intensivmedizinisch behandelt
werden so die erfahrung die zahl der
schwererkrankten wird also
deutschlandweit steigen etwa 3000 aber
alles noch gut handelbar
sie werden die herausforderungen der
zweiten welle hier in aachen meistern
da sind sie sich sicher auch wenn es
allen viel abverlangen wird
kroner und die folgen da stellen sich
viele fragen was es vertretbar wo sind
grenzen für antworten darauf ist unter
anderem der deutsche ethikrat zuständig
ein interview mit der vorsitzende des
expertengremiums gibt es im live stream
um 20 uhr 30 auf unserer internetseite
und in der zdf- heute- app die korona
krise wirbelt seit monaten auch die
wirtschaft durcheinander
bundesarbeitsminister hubertus heil
warnt heute vor einem harten winter am
arbeitsmarkt im oktober gab es
allerdings einen positiven trend
zumindest im vergleich zum vormonat
in diesem monat waren zwei millionen
760.000 menschen arbeitslos das sind 87
1000 weniger als im september
die quote lag bei 6 prozent im vergleich
zum oktober des letzten jahres gab es
allerdings 556.000 arbeitslose mehr noch
eine wichtige personalie jetzt heinrich
bedford strohm will nicht wieder für den
ratsvorsitz der evangelischen kirche in
deutschland kandidieren
es ist gut wenn jemand neues rankommt
neue akzente setzt sagt er
bedford strohm steht 2014 an der spitze
der deutschen protestanten seine
amtszeit läuft im herbst nächsten jahres
aus wie gut bzw schlecht ist der
handyempfang in deutschland fragen wie
diese kann sich jetzt jeder online
selbst beantworten auf der internetseite
der bundesnetzagentur gibt es ab heute
den sogenannten
breitband monitor da kann man in einer
karte nachschauen welche mobilfunknetze
am gesuchten ort zur verfügung stehen
egal ob es um städte dörfer oder
komplett unbewohnte gegenden geht und
damit in dieser sendung haben donnerstag
christin unter sport genau genau gesagt
fußball zweimal champions league zweiter
spieltag und da hat das bundesliga
spitzenreiter rb leipzig bitter erwischt
025 bei manchester united die höchste
niederlage in der königsklasse für das
team von julian nagelsmann der selbst
auch für aufsehen sorgte zumindest
modisch wird ihr auftritt von julian
nagelsmann und seinen leipzigern in
erinnerung bleiben ansonsten war es eher
ein abend zum vergessen dabei die erste
halbzeit noch halbwegs ausgeglichen nur
ein tor für manchester united dieses
nämlich durch ein bisschen hin wird das
wäre jetzt eigentlich über weite
strecken gar nicht mal so schlecht
gemacht haben dann haben wir leider 15
minuten vier tore gekriegt sondern das
verteidigen einfach eingestellt haben
das debakel beginnt in der 74 minute und
nimmt anschließend seinem lauf 2 zu 0
für manchester durch den eingewechselten
markus resch vor der trift vier minuten
später erneut zum 13
nach diesem foul von kacar an material
gibt es völlig zu recht elfmeter den der
gefoulte selbst zum 14 0 verwandelt den
schlusspunkt setzt dann noch einmal
markus radford 15 0 ein denkwürdiges
spiel an dass er sich bestimmt noch
lange und gern erinnern wird im
gegensatz zu den leipzigern und wieder
auf kurs borussia dortmund allerdings
nach einem mühsamen arbeitssieg mit 2 zu
0 gegen zenit st petersburg mit den zwei
späten treffern konnte der bvb einen
weiteren rückschlag nach dem fehlstart
in der königsklasse abwenden
als bvb kapitän marco reus in der 74
minute ausgewechselt wird überwiegt der
frust über eine einfallslose vorstellung
gegen defensive gäste
dass die dortmunder am ende doch noch
jubeln können haben sie diesen
ungeschickten foul kurz darauf von
caravan asa zu verdanken
schäden seien so verwandelten elfmeter
sicher zum 1 0
sie waren zu neun immer hinten und das
ist schwer
das ist schwer sich doch schon zu klären
herr lincoln trifft in der nachspielzeit
noch zum 2 0 dortmund gewinnt verdient
wenn auch nicht schön
durch den sieg sind sie wieder gut im
geschäft im kampf um den einzug in das
champions league achtelfinale
alle vier deutschen bank dann kommt man
aufs wetter es regnete im norden und es
bleibt meist trüb im süden also so groß
ist der unterschied nicht mehr gleich
von gunther tiersch heute-journal 21.45
mit der kollegin marietta slomka von uns
allen im heute 19 uhr team danke für ihr
großes interesse gerne bis morgen aber
erst in allen ein angenehmer abend
[Musik]
und damen liebe zuschauer für eine
verregnete nacht liegt vor uns dieses
massive regengebiet überquert uns in
dieser nacht morgen früh legt dagegen
zwischen der ostsee und dem erzgebirge
bis zu den alpen aber auch tagsüber
bleibt es dann in norddeutschland sehr
trüb es wird immer wieder regnen mit
schauern zum teil und nachmittags könnte
es dann an der nordsee langsam trocken
werden
es weht ein kräftiger westwind dazu und
in der mitte und im süden sind die
meisten regenschauer tagsüber
durchgezogen liegen über dem östlichen
bayern und von den alpen und von
südwesten kann es hier und da am
nachmittag vor allen dingen mehr und
mehr auflockern die temperaturen steigen
es wird etwas wärmer 13 bis 16 grad in
den mittelgebirgen sind zum 11 grad ja
die aussichten für das wochenende es
wird noch ein bisschen wärmer am sonntag
allerdings wird es auch an der nordsee
stürmisch mit regenschauern und am
montag könnte es hier im südwesten 22
grad warm werden
ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen
abend und noch ist es gut